good afternoon now we got too much Mike
that's good ha ha check check everybody
hear me yeah bring it down a little bit
alright keep the house lights up don't
want any shenanigans out there but
welcome everybody to our Tuesday session
both of these men will be joining me for
joining us for the four o'clock session
and the eight o'clock session and what
we hope and have seen some previews of
will be a great lively debate
at a time of campus craziness and
shutting down free speech we're proud at
the CCA to host our first debate that
we've ever had so we welcome these men
we're glad they're here to debate
I will introduce Ian Fletcher more fully
at 8:00 p.m. but he is the author I will
simply say he's the author of free trade
doesn't work what should replace it and
why the leadoff man today for us is
Donald J Boudreaux he's a senior fellow
with the FA Hyack program for Advanced
Study in philosophy politics and
economics at the Mercatus Center at
George Mason University where he holds
the Martha and Nilson gretchen chair for
the study of free-market capitalism
he also serves as an adjunct scholar at
the Cato Institute dr. Boudreaux
received his JD from the University of
Virginia and his PhD from Auburn
University a former president of the
foundation for economic education and an
associate professor of Legal Studies at
and economics at Clemson University his
articles have appeared in numerous
publications including The Wall Street
Journal
US News & World Report and the
Pittsburgh tribune-review he's the
author of the essential Hayek hypocrites
and half-wits a daily dose of sanity
from Caffe Hayek and globalization
please join me in welcoming dr. Donald J
Boudreaux
thank thanks Matt and thanks to
Hillsdale for having me I'm honored to
be here it's it may be the first debate
that Hillsdale has done in this setting
but just over a year ago you and I
debated each other at Hillsdale free
market forum in Atlanta and apparently
that went so swimmingly that they wanted
to to do it again so so here I am so I
believe that free trade is fair trade
and that any restrictions on trade at
least for economic purposes make that
trade unfair and I'll make my case by
starting with a question who owns the
right or the right to the income that
you've earned the question might appear
to be irrelevant to the debate over free
trade and protectionism but I submit
that in this debate this question is
foundational at the very least this
question is one of the few foundational
questions they answer to which is always
at stake when free trade and
protectionism are discussed allow me to
explain with a simple example let's say
that you and your family decide to eat a
healthier diet among the steps that you
take is to eat more fresh tomatoes so
you start buying more locally grown
tomatoes at the farmers market the local
tomato growers are really happy their
incomes rise after several months of
eating lots of tomatoes you and your
family decide that you like tomatoes so
much that you start growing your own
Tomatoes you want to be together it's a
family event you start growing your own
Tomatoes now the local tomato growers
are upset in fact one local tomato
grower complains to the government about
your decision to grow your own Tomatoes
this tomato grower tells the government
truthfully that your decision caused
such a fall and his profits that he had
to layoff one of his workers what he
want us to do ask the head of the
government tomato grower responds that
he wants the government to impose a
punitive tax on you for each tomato that
you grow in your home garden what would
you think of such a demand by this local
tomato grower and how do you think the
government should react to this demand
I'm pretty sure at least if you're like
me but you have no sympathy for this
local
maydel growers demand that you be taxed
if you choose to grow your own Tomatoes
I'm also pretty sure at the government
even the government would be equally
unsympathetic the tomato growers demand
rests on the premise that he the tomato
grower has a right to a portion of your
income a right that he somehow acquired
when you earlier chose to buy some of
his Tomatoes but surely when you spend
your income in whatever ways you spend
your income you know thereby can commit
to continue to spend your income
indefinitely in those particular ways
you're choosing to spend your income as
you do is not a grant to your suppliers
of a perpetual right to that stream of
your income and yet with the government
to tax you for each tomato that you grow
in your garden it would lend credence to
the false premise that each of the
merchants that you patronize including
the tomato grower has a right to a
portion of your income and no decent
government would ever do such a thing
right wrong every protective tariff only
I'm talking about Terrace for economic
reasons not national defense reasons
every protective tariff on imports rests
on the false premise that certain
suppliers have a right to some portion
of your income I ask you do you have a
right to grow tomatoes in your own yard
if doing so diminishes the amount of
tomatoes at some local tomato grower
cells if you answer yes as I believe you
would and should then you affirm that
local tomato growers have no right to
your income you affirm that your income
belongs to you and not to them and yet
if you have a right to reduce the amount
of income you spend buying local
tomatoes because you choose to acquire
tomatoes by growing them yourself why do
you not have a right to reduce the
amount of income you spend buying global
tomatoes by choosing to acquire tomatoes
from a tomato grower who happens to be
in Mexico or in some foreign country if
the local tomato grower has no ethical
claiming your income if you choose to
grow your own tomatoes but what
mysterious process does he come to
possess such a claiming your income when
you choose to buy tomatoes from someone
outside of the country note that in both
cases the effects of your choices on the
local
or grower are identical whether you stop
buying his Tomatoes because you grow
more Tomatoes yourself or because you
import Tomatoes the effects are
identical they're the same and yet while
none of us would tolerate the state
penalizing us whenever we reduce our
demand for domestic outputs by producing
more ourselves many of us tolerate the
state indeed encourage the state to
penalize us whenever we reduce our
demands for domestic outputs by buying
more imports I submit that those who
support protective tariffs are
inconsistent if they do not also support
punitive taxes on home gardening home
cooking home sowing mowing your own lawn
and other do-it-yourself projects after
all home gardening home sewing home
cooking mowing your own lawn these
activities drain demand from local
suppliers of these services causing them
perhaps to lay off some workers I submit
further that those who support tariffs
presume that certain select domestic
suppliers have rights to workers incomes
that Trump the rights of the workers
who've earned those incomes no matter
how much you gussy it up with fancy
rhetoric a protective tariff is a
penalty on consumers who choose to make
their incomes go further by buying
foreign-made Goods a protective tariff
being a penalty on you whenever you
choose to spend a portion of your income
on imports is premise Thanh the ethical
belief that domestic producers have some
claims superior to or at least equal to
your own right to your own income I do
not believe that particular domestic
producers have any ethical claim on your
income yet again supporters of
protective tariffs do believe this the
protectionists will likely assert in
response that there is indeed a
difference between you choosing to grow
your own tomatoes and you choosing to
buy imported Tomatoes but this assertion
is false
there is absolutely no economic
difference between you reducing the
amounts of tomatoes that you buy from
domestic growers because you grow more
Tomatoes yourself and you're reducing
the amount of tomatoes that you buy from
domestic growers because you buy more
Tomatoes for Mexico none no economic
difference whatsoever
every ill economic effect that you can
point to is being
by an increase in tomato imports is also
caused if you choose to grow more
Tomatoes yourself do tomato imports
destroy some jobs on - on domestic
tomato farms yep but so - if you grow
more Tomatoes yourself at home might
more tomato imports bankrupt some
domestic tomato growers yep same thing
though if you grow more Tomatoes
yourself well tomato imports put
downward pressure on the wages of
workers on tomato farms quite possibly
but so - if you grow more tomatoes at
home yourself if you fall for
protectionists claim that the economic
consequences of free trade are often too
harsh to endure then you must also
conclude that many ordinary everyday
freedoms that you cherish have economic
consequences that are often too harsh to
endure the reason is that anytime you
change your spending patterns for
whatever reason you reduce demands for
some domestic producers outputs and
hence put in peril the jobs of some
particular workers when about 20 years
ago Americans went in a big way for the
Atkins diet remember that everyone was
eating beef and chicken and no more
carbohydrates bakers and Brewers
suffered while butchers benefited should
government therefore attempt to protect
Brewers and bakers by obstructing our
freedoms to change our eating habits
what Americans today be wealthier if to
protect jobs of workers in typewriter
factories and workers and secretarial
pools had been protected by government
in the 1980s and 1990s by restrictions
on our abilities to buy personal
computers and what about the polio
vaccine should government have prevented
parents from vaccinating their children
against this debilitating and sometimes
fatal disease after all the use of the
vaccine destroyed lots of jobs and
factories producing wheelchairs crutches
and iron lung machines many of you will
think that such examples are silly or
inappropriate but they're not each of
these examples and I can offer many many
more is of economic change that
unleashes every one of the economic
effects that are asserted by
protectionist to justify tariffs and
other obstructions on our freedoms to
conduct peaceful commerce with
foreigners now I know from experience
our protectionist will respond to this
they think they can identify differences
but every day
that they identified turns out upon
inspection to be no relevant difference
at all
for example the protections might the
protectionist might say that when you
grow more tomatoes at home foreigners
don't get any dollars unlike when you
buy more imported Tomatoes when
foreigners do get dollars
well let's true enough but this fact
doesn't have the economic significance
that protection has asserted to have
foreigners are just like us they engage
in trade in order to improve their lives
they don't send us tomatoes or any other
stuff for free or because they love us
they send us stuff because they want
something from us in return when
foreigners sell us Tomatoes it's true
that we pay them with dollars Bota
foreigners do with these dollars our
foreigners so deeply fond of George
Washington Abraham Lincoln and other
dead American statesmen that they want
to accumulate as many as possible
monochrome pictures of these people of
course not but by the way if they did if
all foreigners wanted was literally our
money that would be the best of all
possible worlds for us Americans
unfortunately that's not true they
returned the dollars to America Fars do
with dollars just what you do with
dollars spend them or invest them and
dollars are spent and invested
ultimately in the United States let's
say that you buy tomatoes from a Mexican
farmer this Mexican tomato grower might
then spend his dollars that he got from
you buying an iPhone this is an example
which although assembled by the way in
China is largely american-made if
reckoned by the total value of the
inputs that American producers
contribute to the iPhone compared to the
total value of the inputs contributed by
foreign producers this Mexicans purchase
of the iPhone with the dollar as he got
from you when you bought tomatoes from
him supports jobs in the American
information technology sector note that
if you grow your own Tomatoes you might
do the same thing the money you save not
buying tomatoes from a domestic tomato
grower might persuade you to buy a new
iPhone the economic consequences of your
decision to grow your own Tomatoes is
identical to the consequences of your
decision to buy imported Tomatoes less
out less output from domestic tomato
growers more output from a US consumer
electronics firm or perhaps the Mexican
who sells you some of these Tomatoes
invests his dollars say by buying stock
on the New York Stock Exchange this
purchase will increase America's trade
deficit the contrary to what we're told
incessantly by protectionist a trade
deficit for America is not bad it's good
when Mexican farmers buy stock in
American companies the dollars returned
to America just as surely as when they
buy an iPhone from Apple or buy lumber
from georgia-pacific or take a family
activity at Disney World but in only the
first case does America's trade deficit
rise the reason for this fact is merely
that international investments are
recorded on a different account and an
accounting account from now on which
imports and exports are recorded
investments are recorded on the capital
account while imports and exports are
recorded on the current account here's a
fact that seems to be a secret to
protectionist although to economists
it's well known another name for a trade
deficit is capital account surplus or
capital surplus for short in the very
same official accounts in which is
recorded that America runs a trade
deficit more practice peaking a current
account deficit that I'll use the
colloquial trade deficit whenever
America runs a trade deficit it's also
recorded that America runs a capital
surplus of the very same dollar amount
put differently the term US trade
deficit
really means the amount of investment
funds that America receives from abroad
a US trade deficit means nothing more
than that we Americans imported more
during some period than we exported
during that period it does not mean
contrary to the impression conveyed by
protectionists that dollars are draining
out of America or that there is a
resulting decrease in the demand for
outputs of American firms whoever sold
those shares of stock to the Mexican
tomato grower now has the dollars and
that person will either spend or invest
those dollars in the u.s. let's say that
the person who sold the stock uses the
proceeds to buy a new iPhone in this
case the dollars that you originally
spent buying tomatoes returned to
America as demand for the iPhone the
less than if the Mexicans
if it directly bought the iPhone the
only difference is that in the first
case and or in the case when when the
the iPhone is bought by the Mexican
directly there's no increase in the
trade deficit but when the Mexican
tomato grower buys stock on the New York
Stock Exchange and then the seller of
the stock then buys the iPhone there is
an increase in the trade deficit but the
two effects are the same
now you might dispute my claim that the
two cases are the same you might say
that when foreigners buy stock in
American companies or otherwise invest
in America that's different than
foreigners simply buying American
outputs and I'll grant your point there
is indeed a difference one that I'll
explore in just a moment but I here want
to emphasize that there is no difference
in the two cases of the sort that is
frequently asserted by those who stir up
fears of US trade deficits in both cases
again that of a foreigner buying
American exports and that of a foreigner
investing in America the dollars that
Americans spend on imports return here
and are spent here further dollars
invested in America support American
jobs no less than do dollars spent on
purchases of American exports I've
already given you one example namely
when the American seller of stock uses
the proceeds to buy an iPhone but
consider also the effects on the company
whose stock is sold the price of that
stock Rises the wealth many of whom are
Americans of holders of that stock their
spending power and wealth rise because
of the foreign demand for the stock that
company because its stock price is
higher now has an easier time getting
capital easier time investing and
growing one myth that protection is
spread about trade deficits is that such
deficits imply that Americans are
becoming poorer as foreigners acquire
more dollar denominated assets yeah well
you can't imagine such a situation it's
not our reality and it's not a necessity
the amount of capital in the world or in
any country is not fixed in market
economies it can and it does grow
foreign investment in the US generally
expands the amount of capital at work in
a mare
such as the number in size of factories
the amounts of research and development
and the specialized training of workers
let's look again at the American who
sells shares of stock to the Mexican
tomato grower suppose it instead of
using those dollars to buy an iPhone the
American adds them to funds that he uses
to finance a new business a new IT
business and you a new app business that
seems to be the place where you make
money now if that American business is
successful the net wealth of the
American increases also America's
capital stock increases and if you care
about such calculations the net wealth
of Americans as a group increases now
you can see why a moment ago I granted
that there is indeed an economic
difference between the case of
foreigners spending all of their dollars
buying American exports and thus not
causing the trade deficit to rise in the
case when foreigners invest some of
their dollars in America and thus caused
the US trade deficit to rise investments
by foreigners in America are even better
for the American economy
there are purchases by foreigners of
American exports investment directly
increases the size and quality of the
capital stock consumption doesn't think
of the matter this way when someone
cashes out his dollars for American
goods he takes something out of the
economy he takes something away from the
rest of us for example the food that he
eats at a restaurant the car that he
drives for his personal use the metal
that's in the golf clubs that he plays
golf with that's true it's something
that he earned the right to take out of
the economy there's nothing wrong with
his doing so the ultimate reason we
produces to consume but he nevertheless
consumes resources I saw the call a
consumption but had this person instead
invested the resources would not be
consumed by him but instead put toward
the production of other goods and
services making the economy grow whoever
chooses today to forego current
consumption whoever saves frees up
resources for use in building a factory
manufacturing a bulldozer training
workers whatever the investment activity
it increases the flow of consumption
goods tomorrow it makes us wealthier
tomorrow whoever saves is among
humankind's benefactors importantly the
straightforward but vitally important
distinction
consumption on the one hand and savings
and investment on the other hand holds
regardless of the identities of the
persons doing the savings and investing
it holds whether the saver and investor
is male or female
old or young taller short blue-eyed a
brown-eyed foreigner or fellow citizen
admittedly the term trade deficits
sounds ominous but here we have a case
of highly misleading labeling because
every cent of the US trade deficit
returns to America on the capital
account that is as investment overall
American trade is fully balanced and
it's balanced by foreigners adding to
the capital stock of America many of the
resources that they choose to invest
here the case for welcoming trade
deficit is even stronger when we take
account of the diversity of ideas and
creativity contrary to the opinions of
so many people on the political left
productive investment investment that
grows an economy is not a mindless
mechanical low-risk activity many of you
know that it's a creative activity and
it's one that carries with it no little
amount of risk when foreign
entrepreneurs and investors commit their
funds to the US economy they often share
with us not only their capital but their
creativity and their risk-taking
they bring their new ideas for different
products to produce and for different
and more efficient means of production
to our shores
sometimes these ideas will be inferior
to those of American investors and in
those cases those foreign investments
will fail but in this world of ours of
7.5 billion people it's ludicrous to
suppose that all of the best
entrepreneurial ideas are here in
America we're less than 5% of the world
population when foreigners put into
operation their new investment ideas
here in America that proved to be
superior to existing ideas creative
destruction occurs this process is no
different than when we Americans put to
operation our new investment ideas that
proved to be superior to the existing
ones the economy grows creative
destruction occurs the late great Julian
Simon explained that the ultimate
resource is the human mind in a free
society it's the human mind that turns
raw materials into resources that
creates resources the likes of Patrol
iron or rubber trees even land not
naturally resources despite the fact
that we call them natural resources
these things are no more useful to
humans than to hamsters without human
creativity's first figuring out how to
transform them into things that are
useful to us and to do so in an
economical way when foreigners invest in
the American economy they add their
creativity to our creativity more
resources have created more goods and
services are created sure foreign
investors profit when they invest
successfully in America just as American
investors profit when we invest
successfully there's nothing wrong with
that to profit is to create value when
any company in a market economy profits
everyone benefits from that from that
creation of value our economy grows to
lament foreign investment in the u.s. is
to emit not only the fact that
foreigners pay us the great compliment
of believing that our economy is a
promising and trustworthy place to put
their funds to lament foreign investment
in the US is also to lament the inflow
into America of capital and of that
ultimate resource human creativity now
there's much more to say on this
important matter and I don't doubt you
have doubts about my argument I'm
prepared to extend and to defend my
argument but like all resources time is
scarce so on an end was just a few
graphs that I have managed to have eight
and a half minutes so I did a little bit
of guesswork here not quite it's
informed guesswork I do a lot of
speaking on trade I know the concerns
that people have so I have some pictures
that I want to show you that back up
some of what I say and that dispel some
myths that people typically have about
trade let's see if this works here I
need a creative human mind
is it
okay alright so these two lines the
Green Line is the u.s. civilian labor
force from 1950 until 2016 or 2015 the
yellow line is the actual number of
full-time jobs in US labor force you can
see that as the labor force rose the
number of jobs rose today it's about one
hundred and fifty five percent higher
than it was 67 years ago I show you the
square to show that the number of jobs
in an economy contrary to what a lot of
people think is not fixed it's more
function of the labor size of the labor
force rather than of trade how do I
advance it the left clicker okay okay
and so yeah actually the laser and so on
this graph that yellow line again is
jobs the same yellow line you saw
earlier the green line now is the
inflation-adjusted dollars of imports
into the u.s. from 1950 until today and
as you can see as the imports increase
it had no discernible effect on the
number of jobs in the economy this is
the another graph showing pretty much
the same thing except now we have
imports as a percentage of GDP and
unemployment and you can see that as
imports rise from 1970 it has no
discernible effect on the unemployment
rate which is more a function of the
condition of our labor markets and
fiscal and monetary policy rather than
of trade policy this graph we have the
yellow line is kind of faint I know this
shows real hourly compensation for 1950
an inflation adjusted hourly pay of
American workers the Green Line again is
imports and as you can see the
particularly a stark increase in the
rate of imports starting in the 80s has
no discernible effect on the pay of
workers worker pay is determined by
worker productivity by and large
this is a graph from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics the blue line shows worker
compensation the red line shows the
value of hourly worker productivity on
average from 1945 until today as you can
see according to and it's a confirmation
of economic theory as productivity Rises
for workers so too does K this graph
shows the the Green Line is the US trade
deficit from 1950 current account
deficit and the yellow line again is
employment that yellow line I showed you
earlier and so from 1950 until the mid
70s there was virtually no trade deficit
trade deficits really began in a big way
starting in the 70s and trade deficit
increase which is shown by a decrease in
that green line because it trade
deficits a negative value and the
increase in the trade deficit has no
discernible impact contrary to what
we're constantly told unemployment this
is yet another way to look at that the
top line is unemployment and the bottom
line is betrayed deficit as a percentage
of GDP and the two are not correlated in
any way I mentioned earlier that the
trade deficit is or the current account
deficit get more precisely is a mirror
image of the capital account the light
blue line is the trade deficit the dark
blue line is the capital account you can
see that they're virtually mirror images
for one another I can't emphasize this
enough whenever someone says trade
deficit whenever someone laments a
rising US trade deficit they are
lamenting a rising increase in the size
of the US capital stock why that is
lamentable I will never know sometimes
it said that well the trade deficit
means that our capital stock is falling
this is this is from the st. Louis Fed
this is real private non-residential so
not counting housing fixed investment
factories and and and buildings and
farms and you can see the values is
inflation adjusted the value this is
since nineteen
I think this starts in 1965 maybe 1965
up until it's given 1970 it start second
before that and it has risen over that
time room if this is inflation adjusted
I skipped one and I don't know how to
get back some people worry that as
foreigners that's okay as foreigners
invest more in the US economy as they
had been doing especially since the mid
1970s that must come at the expense of
Americans well this line shows from 1945
the inflation adjusted of total
financial assets of American households
and nonprofit organizations Oh what is
happening it's mayhem oh now this thing
works okay I think I have it now I think
I can all right okay
great of mine so this shows basically
the the financial wealth of American
households from 1945 until today and as
you can see this is 1975 or there abouts
is about when the trade deficit started
to increase and that has had no effect
on oh I'm very skilled at this it's had
no effect on the financial wealth of
Americans contrary to what we're often
told this is there's a scattered diagram
that was put together by one of my
graduate students looking at all the
OECD countries and their trade deficits
or trade balances and there is no
correlation between oh and on the
horizontal axis we have per capita GDP
and there seems to be no correlation
between any particular countries trade
deficit or if they want to go through
some of these a little bit more quickly
this is a graph from the Heritage
Foundation which many of you know
looking at a trade freedom
and the countries that are that that's
the nations with more trade freedom have
less poverty so this is the amount of
poverty in the countries that have most
the top fourth countries that most trade
freedom only four point five percent
average poverty right there
the Contras with the least trade freedom
have the most poverty so the more trade
freedom we have the less poverty we have
how much time one minute I perhaps later
I'll get to show you some other graphs
but just literally just yesterday I was
at my office and an academic journal
arrived in my mailbox
it's from it's called economic affairs
it's a very well respected refereed
journal and there's an article in it I
literally grabbed the syllabus walking
out to to teach my class before flying
here this morning it's an article in it
written by someone whose name I cannot
pronounce and its title the impact of
multilateral trade liberalisation and
economic development some empirical
evidence it's a typical academic title
and here's the finding of this article
which I read on the plane this morning
and it found to be very well done the
analysis is this analysis has been
conducted on a panel data set of 155
countries from the time period 1954 1995
to 2014 the empirical results strongly
suggest that multilateral trade
liberalisation promotes countries
economic development that is it raises
their real per capita income in addition
this positive impact is invert is
unevenly distributed across countries as
countries that have had a higher level
of economic development
such as the United States benefit more
from multilateral trade liberalisation
than to countries with lower
developmental levels the argument for
free trade is very powerful I have more
to show you but my time is also is now
out so thank you all
[Applause]
thank you dr. Boudreau the the format
which I failed to mention earlier will
have ten minute response and then we'll
open it up for questions
and then we'll do the reverse at the 8
p.m.
mr. Fletcher will start off ok I'd like
to begin by the little point that
Professor Boudreau and I checked before
this began he's a libertarian so
strictly speaking and he's said this in
other contexts he does not believe that
it's ethically legitimate to care about
the economic interests of Americans as
opposed to anybody else so I would
respectfully suggest that you can debate
the ethics of that but it does mean that
he's not a rational person for Americans
to listen to ok now other little point I
wanted to make before get into anything
is all these numbers about unemployment
and how trade problems don't cause
unemployment yes that is literally true
the problem is they cause
underemployment which is somebody loses
a $30 an hour job working in an auto
plant and goes and works for $8 an hour
at Walmart so that's why the crude
unemployment figures don't don't show
the damage now what I want to discuss in
detail is this issue of the trade
deficit which Professor Boudreau and I
seem to agree is how you keep score on
this thing now I'm going to tell you the
trade deficit very much does matter
because as one of Professor boudreaux's
heroes Milton Friedman once said there
ain't no such thing as a free lunch now
here's how the trade deficit works when
we get goods from some foreign country
there's only three ways that that can
happen number one is if we give the
foreigners goods that we produce today
in return number two is if we promise to
give them goods we're going to produce
in the future a number three is if we
give them goods that we already produced
in the past I'll explain what that means
goods we produce today is when we
imported
from Japan and we sell some entity in
Japan a Boeing 747 goods we produced in
the past means that in exchange for
Toyota we sell some entity in Japan and
this is all intermediated complexly with
financial institutions and so forth but
we sell them shares in Microsoft or part
of a limited partnership interest in a
shopping center in Dallas or something
like that goods we promise to produce in
the future means we go into debt and
that says we're not going to give you
anything now but in the future we're
going to give you something now if you
think about this at this level of
abstraction it should be pretty clear
that if we're not offering goods we
produce yesterday goods we produce today
or goods we promise to produce tomorrow
then we're trading with the North Pole
because we're trading with Santa okay we
really are getting something for nothing
now here's where the trade deficit comes
in when we run a trade deficit it means
that our exports in this country don't
equal our imports which means we are not
paying for the goods that we import with
goods we produce today now that leaves
only two options then it's either goods
we produced yesterday or goods we will
produce in the future so that means
either we're giving foreigners in
exchange for their goods we're giving
them shares of stock financial assets or
we're going into debt and it's assuming
debt to some foreign entity now why is
this bad the reason it's bad is that
when you sell off your existing assets
or going to debt to someone you own less
and you owe more this is one of the few
things that really is the same with a
household and a country to return to the
professor's favorite example of tomatoes
the analogy is like suppose you're
living some big old house and it's full
of all this furniture you don't really
use and in order to prop up your
lifestyle you invite antique dealer over
and you sell off your grandma's couch
you sell off her bureau drawer so on and
so forth you're selling off your
existing asset to buy stuff you want to
consume today that may be ok but it does
mean that you own less stuff your net
worth is less your wealth is less going
into debt it's the same thing there are
reasons why people go into debt in this
in this life but it does mean that you
are less rich it does mean that your
economic well-being is less now I don't
want to elaborate on this because this
is not something where my elaborating
will help what will help is if you
reason through these steps on your own
you should see with clarity that the
trade deficit really is a problem and
it's not a small number it's around it's
been fluctuating four or five hundred
billion dollars a year now for years and
in the short run this costs us quality
of jobs as I said not quantity of jobs
of quality of jobs it also runs down our
industrial base that is we don't just
not produce these goods we lose the
capacity to produce goods which is
something which always gets ignored in
this kind of libertarian thinking yes
you can buy from abroad okay fine that's
cheap but you also have to worry about
not the immediate act of consumption but
the effect on your capability to produce
that's all for now I think we're going
to open it up to the floor thank you
so we'll do a couple minutes if you want
to just stay seated here and respond and
then as soon as he's done we'll take
questions so I have two minutes for
response very quickly I with respect I
do not understand that whatever
definition of libertarian mr. Fletcher
is is working with it does not mean that
in Bluebird attorneys don't care about
Americans the case I made for trade was
all about how it helped Americans and I
believe it does I believe it also helps
foreigners I see nothing wrong with
helping foreigners but the the chief
case for trade that I made here is of
its benefit to Americans
secondly the there is a fourth option
that mr. Fletcher overlooks about the
trade deficit when foreigners invest
here they get they often get repaid with
goods that they produce here the BMW
factory in Greer South Carolina not only
creates jobs for Americans and reduces
automobiles and Americans can purchase
and Americans can export it produces the
payments the profits out of which the
German investors get repaid it is simply
not the kibbeh cuz the capital stock in
the world is not fixed when our trade
deficit Rises that does not mean that we
necessarily are made poor it can be that
but in fact it's not I have a question
just to ask you you can probably it'll
be rhetorical Belgian but if I ask you
at what period in history was America's
manufacturing output at its peak its
inflation adjusted manufacturing output
at its peak what would you say today
yeah so and I have I have some graphs of
that I can show you if time allows later
the size of the capital stock the
monetary value of the capital stock in
the United States today is that an
all-time high it's not the case that we
have been basically
the dining room furniture into the
fireplace in order to get in order to
heat our homes the capital stock has
been growing it has been growing in part
not only because of Americans savings
and the attractiveness of the American
economy but also because of the
investments at farms make you don't I
get a response please raise your hand
and the mic will be brought for you to
to you questions please not life stories
that would be great question so you gave
the example of the tomatoes and the
Mexican farmer bought something over
here suppose in the Mexican farmer
bought some Mexican bananas or some
Chinese sneakers to broaden that idea
the whole argument assumes that people
are gonna want stuff from us and
projecting into the future is that a
guarantee that they're gonna want stuff
from us yes it is a guarantee that if
they want our dollars that that means
they want something from us the
particular person who sells tomatoes to
Americans he might not want something
from us but how can he spend dollars in
Mexico he has to transform those dollars
into Mexican pesos why would any Mexican
bank give that person valuable Mexican
pesos in exchange for pictures of
Abraham Lincoln and George Washington if
someone in Mexico did not want to spend
those dollars or invest those dollars in
the United States
and as I said so it has to be the case
that the American dollars come back here
so that they're trapped if they buy they
get it are they trapped if they take
American dollars can't they spend them
in China yes but then why would the
Chinese accept the dollars the Chinese
I'll tell you that they accept the
dollars because the Chinese want to
spend the dollars here in fact that's
how world truth will get further and say
they don't want our dollars period what
well that would be the best of all
worlds for Americans and we could then
we get free stuff we would get Tomatoes
and cars and steal and exchange for
pieces of paper that would be the best
of all worlds I wish that would happen
and unfortunately it's not what happens
the Chinese accept dollars from the
Mexicans only because for the same
reason you accept dollars if would you
accept monopoly money for something
valuable no the reason is because you
know you can't spend it you accept
dollars for something valuable only
because you know you can spend it and
the Chinese are no different than you
sir
sure is this thing on there we go I
think we've slipped once or twice
already into a couple of conceptual
tangles that unfortunately I can't make
go away because I've been doing this for
years the one thing I can tell you is
the easiest mistake to make when
thinking these issues through like when
Professor Boudreau just said there's a
fourth option it's all a baseline trick
you got to be very careful considering
what baseline you are comparing with the
outcome that you got because the
question is not are you better off or
worse off the question is are you better
off or worse off than you would have
been if the other policy under debate
were being discussed sorry sorry we're
being adopted now for example when
Professor said okay you have Germans own
a factory in the United States they make
BMWs some of which are exported so that
pays for the money that they spent
building the factory the question is not
whether that's true the question is
would Americans be richer if Americans
rather than Germans owned the factory
the answer is yes because that Americans
rather than Germans would be receiving
the profits that's the question you have
to ask about foreign investment it's not
are we better off having foreign
investment or not having foreign
investment
the question is are you better off given
any factory office building whatever
productive acid are you better off with
us owning it or with foreigners owning
it and the answer is we're better off
with us owning it because then it's
value is part of our wealth and its
profits are part of our income hello
thank you both for coming to Hillsdale
and us speaking today and later on today
professor bruto your argument seems to
be predicated upon free trade as a
universal mutually beneficial act for
the US and any foreign entities that we
happen to engage in but my question for
you and I apologize just it's a slight
bit me entering but just it seems that
your phrasing it is solely an economic
issue independent of any potential
social or cultural effects and so when
you talk about the benefit to the US and
different things like that I'm wondering
how much of a benefit is it when you
have to it seems that you have by
necessity you have to factor in the
cultural and social effects that
happened with these foreign entities
because we're not just acting in
isolation it can't just be an economic
issue because it's not just dollars it's
also people so could you speak on that
please first of all I have two responses
very quickly the main arguments against
free trade are almost always posed in
economic terms it's just it's as Ian
does the argument is that it reduces
Americans jobs it reduces Americans
wealth I'm happy to go along with those
arguments but I agree with you that that
the the fuller context in which free
trade should be discussed is is larger
it's not just economic and here's one of
the the non-economic effects of free
trade that I like very much it is
consistent with freedom it's consistent
with Liberty it is not a system in which
government bureaucrats get to
superintend your spending decisions or
your investment decisions any system of
protection is a system when you have
government bureaucrats in the capital
penalizing you when you spend your money
in ways that they don't like I find that
to be culturally offensive
I think the answer to that it's real
easy to wave the flag and talk about
liberty equals free trade it's a lot
harder to explain why all the founding
fathers were protectionist Saul all the
presidents up until 1950s
it's very strange George Washington
protectionist Lincoln protectionist do
they know something about Liberty I'm
not sure other point I would make is
free trade is quote unquote free trade
because in the world in reality free
trade means the US and a few other
countries like the UK adopt free trade
it for real other major players do not
so in reality what free trade means is
you adopt this policy you're building up
a nuclear-armed dictatorship that
despises the United States and is on the
verge of edging a society as a
superpower and if you think that arming
Beijing is a victory for liberty in this
world I don't know what to say gentlemen
thank you for coming I guess mine is
gonna be more observational which will
lead to a question I have worked for two
major US corporations both of which I've
watched spend themselves into a demise
one being DuPont the other being General
Motors and if you look at flyover
country this place is full of empty
factories which I don't understand and
that's as things have moved overseas and
what we call free trade Japan comes here
to trade with us try to find an American
car in Japan you'll have a hard time and
so based on at least the reality of
partly of what I'm seeing I'm asking an
open question of how do you protect
American investment and American value
with the trade proposition
the fact is Americans are wealthier
today than we have been at any time the
American capital stock is higher it's
simply a myth to think that they're
always closed down factories you can
find some of course in some locales are
doing worse than others but some locales
are doing better than others you can't
just look at one individual town one
individual place of one individual
company it's not the case that America
is an industrial decline it said all the
time but repeating a falsehood does not
make that falsehood true I'm afraid
that's an example of exactly what I was
warning you against a few minutes ago
namely the baseline trick yes it's true
that the United States is wealthier than
it's been at any point in its history
that's not what's relevant what's may I
finish no I didn't even say what's
what's relevant what's relevant is not
we're Americans our level of wealth X
greater than level of wealth Y in the
past where we are relative to where we
should be we should be a much richer
country as we would be if we had not d
industrialized vast sections of this
country and if you think the
deindustrialization is a myth can you
explain to me why the United States Air
Force cannot put a single plane into the
sky that is does not contain components
made by likely adversaries one of the
great benefits of free trade is that the
global supply chain now is truly global
yes of course the Americas are able to
put more and better planes in the sky
precisely because we get creativity from
all around the world we get the luckiest
influence from all around the world we
can if we relied only upon things
literally that we're extracted from the
United States are our fighting power
would be less not greater I agree with
you at the baselines important issue my
question is from mr. Boudreau uh
for mr. Fletcher professor Boudreau
argued in his speech that when we
purchase foreign goods the dollars are
returned to our economy whether through
capital or through investments and so
although there is a trade deficit in
goods
there's no trade deficit when you factor
in the total economic flow of money in
and out of the US and when you gave your
response
you simply restated the definition of a
trade deficit and I'm wondering if you
have a response to the argument when you
consider the total economic flow of
money in and out of the country was that
a question for mr. me yeah basically as
far as I can tell on the pure
technicality of it - some verbal
scrambling x' we're not in disagreement
about the fundamentals here it's just
that I would respectfully submit that
Professor Boudreau is not thinking
through the fact that when you have
foreign investment that's all well and
good but it means that some foreign
entity rather than some Americans own
the assets so yes I would rather that a
factory an office building or some other
productive asset be in existence than it
not exist but what would be even better
is if it existed and belonged to us not
to them that's my point about baselines
which also goes to his point about u.s.
wealth being an all-time high yeah and
it should be even higher if half of
Cleveland wasn't rubble
hi my questions for dr. Fletcher or mr.
Fletcher you mentioned that the
unemployment rate was not a good
indicator of the effect of the trade yet
when dr. Brad Rowe showed some slides
there was a slide that that showed the
earnings per hour worked continue to
increase
even though traded increased which
didn't seem to support your argument
what's your response to that my argument
my response is pretty much the same
response I've given you again which is
even if you look at something being at
an all-time high or a figure that is you
know perhaps not the worst thing in the
world because the United States is still
a first world country you're still
looking about this country not being
remotely where it should be just because
average earnings are whatever they are I
would respectfully suggest you look at
what those earnings are multiply that
out by a $2,000 a year and ask whether
you could live on that because there are
definitely people in this country are
not earning what they ideally would be
if this economy was was run properly so
I I noticed mr. Fletcher that you have
been focusing a little more on how free
trade has harmed producers specifically
and so my question is mr. Budrow was of
the opinion that free trade benefits
both producers and consumers and so I
would like to ask you if we get Goods
cheaper from overseas and consumers are
better off so how under protectionism or
other things how would consumers be
better off okay you've got two issues
there the first thing is that if you do
what I would like to see happen which is
to move the US trade situation from a
deficit to a balance then you're no
longer having an increase every year in
how much of this country we've sold off
and how much we've in effect mortgaged
so you're no longer going to have this
continuing drag on our net worth which
can nevertheless increase but it's not
going to increase as much as it
otherwise would the other issue is the
benefit to
summers in order to be a consumer you
have to have a job
okay that's elementally obvious everyone
except economists as I as I pointed out
you're talking about people who lose $30
an hour jobs working in automobile
manufacturing and end up working for $8
an hour Walmart the crude unemployment
figures don't tell you anything thank
you both for being here my question is
for mr. Fletcher you mentioned that
you'd prefer and in you'd prefer for a
plant asset like a factory to be
american-made I was wondering why that
matters from an economic standpoint if a
foreign investment can create a plant
asset like it liking it like a factory
that's cheaper last longer and employ
people quicker which increases output
what does it matter if it's American or
not where's the economic incentive
where's the economics behind it being
specifically American okay you're
talking about two separate issues there
the first thing is the location of the
asset in America or abroad and the
second thing is the ownership of the
asset whether it belongs to an American
or foreigner clearly we're better off if
some plant for example is built but
we're also better off if that is owned
by Americans because then the value of
the thing is part of our net worth and
we're better and then we're better off
because we collect the profits rather
than someone else as I said it's a
baseline issue yes we're better off with
the thing getting built but we would be
even better off if it were ours let me
say a word on that
Ian assumes that the amount of capital
in the world is fixed he assumes that
that if a foreigner owned something that
means our of capital ownership must fall
the amount of capital in the world is
not fixed foreigners can own things and
we can own more things too I would be
better off if I owned Microsoft there's
no doubt about it I would be better off
if I owned Amazon I would love to switch
places financially with Jeff Bezos
of course
but the fact that Jeff Bezos owns Amazon
doesn't mean I'm worse off and if they
had if there had been some some
prohibition on Jeff Bezos creating and
developing Amazon that doesn't mean that
I therefore would have created and
developed Amazon the fact that Jeff
Bezos created Amazon means that he
brought his creativity to that the world
was made richer by him I am made richer
by his doing that his doing I didn't
stop me from investing in whatever ways
I wanted to invest and had he been
prevented from investing I almost surely
didn't have the creativity and the
gumption to do what he did and the same
thing holds true for all Americans and
with respect to any foreign investment
in the United States
that's a brilliant refutation of
something I didn't say telling me
telling me that the amount of capital in
the world or in the United States is not
fixed is like telling me the height of a
tree is not fixed yes it can grow over
time and it does but at any given point
any given point in time yes the amount
of capital in the world is fixed and if
you look up the figures of the IMF you
can find out no really it's like a tree
it can grow it's not fixed forever but
at any given moment in time there is a
certain amount of wealth in the world
these figures can be looked up so far as
I know they're not especially
controversial so yes there are issues of
we own something or someone else does
one doesn't have to have a zero sum view
of the world to understand there is
rivalry in the world so you accept the
Marxist view that capital grows rather
automatically knows automatically that's
just that grows not automatically
capital growth because people
productively put it to work in
competitive market economies and when
you when you restrain their ability to
compete you reduce the amount of capital
accumulation capital doesn't grow
automatically like a tree it grows
because of human action I think you
understand professor that I'm simply
using the analogy of a tree to make one
simple point about something that
changes over time but at any given point
has a finite size if you want to abuse
the analogy in to asserting that I think
capital is made of wood too many might
as well you know do that do that too
the point stands thank you both for
being here today
so mr. Fletcher you mentioned a couple
times today that free trade leads to the
underemployment of Americans so I'm just
wondering if protectionism leads to a
lessening of the real income of
Americans through increased prices how
is there an economic difference between
the decreased real income along with
underemployment thank you you're
absolutely correct that protectionism
comes at a cost that's the last thing I
or anybody who knows anything about this
would hush up but I talked about it in
my book free trade doesn't work the
question is what is that cost now the
first thing we can see is a lot of this
extra income we think we get by having
quote unquote free it's not free as I
said but quote unquote free trade that's
just selling off assets and going into
debt
so if you impose a policy that makes
that go away the cost is well you've
reduced people's ability to become
poorer so I'm not sure that that's a bad
thing to get rid of the second thing is
yes you do have a higher a higher cost
for goods in the short run if you
prevent people from just buying you know
the cheapest product but what you avoid
there by is you avoid the decay of
America's productive capacity you avoid
the decline of our industries I mean I
read this morning that China has just
got the first preliminary approval to ik
to export the c919 aircraft to the
United States whose equivalent of a
Boeing 737 over time given the kind of
subsidies that they put behind their
industries they're quite capable of
wiping out our aircraft industry and if
they can take that out there's nothing
they can't take out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
think of more questions and debate over
dinner and we'll be back at eight
o'clock thank you very much
[Applause]